Path Tracer and Unreal Engine uses an approximation for caustic lighting.
The complex light patterns created when light reflects or
refracts off of shiny or transparent surfaces like glass or metal.
True caustics are physically accurate, but very noisy and slow to converge,
especially on materials with low roughness,
that have like smooth or mirror-like surfaces.
They can take an impractical number of samples to render correctly.
To keep images smooth and reduce noise, Unreal's Path Tracer automatically
enables an approximation that simplifies the caustic calculations
instead of fully simulating them.
This is controlled by the console command r.pathtracing.approximateCaustics
and setting the value, the default being 1, and it's on by default.
When working with caustics in Path Tracer, it's important to know the difference
between refractive and approximate caustics.
Using the denoiser lets you preview what true refractive caustics would look like
if the renderer had enough time to fully converge,
showing you the physically accurate results.
In contrast, approximate caustics generate a production-ready image much faster,
using a simplified model that greatly reduces noise.
You can toggle this feature on with the console command r.pathtracing.approximateCaustics
and using 1 or 0 to enable or disable respectively.
Finally, here are some CVars commonly used to modify path tracing
and path tracing results within Unreal Engine.
In the next section, we're going to cover using skylights, particularly with Path Tracer.